IMF AND DAVID MALPASS OF WORLD
BANK ON THIS PROGRAM TO TALK
ABOUT THE SITUATION.
SO RICHARD BRANSEN OF THE VIRGIN
GROUP SAID THE TIME HAS COME FOR
THE WEST TO STOP FUNDING PUTIN'S
WAR ON UKRAINE, WRITTEN AN OPEN
LETTER SAYING THE FUTURE OF A
SOVEREIGN SELF-DETERMINED
UKRAINE IS INEXTRICABLY LINKED
TO DEMOCRACY ITSELF, MUST RAMP
UP SUPPORT SERIOUSLY AND
CITIZENS MUST PLAY THEIR PART
TOO.
RICHARD WITH ME NOW FROM NEW
YORK.
IT'S A VERY BLUNT, STRAIGHT
FORWARD LETTER THAT YOU'VE
WRITTEN.
IT FOLLOWS OTHERS THAT YOU'VE
DONE, WHAT I FOUND INTERESTING,
RICHARD IS THAT YOU'RE COMING UP
WITH PRACTICAL SOLUTIONS TO WHAT
YOU SAY IS THE WORST OFFENSE,
WHICH IS THE CONTINUING PURCHASE
OF RUSSIAN OIL.
>> YES.
AND I THINK, I KNOW A LOT OF
BUSINESS PEOPLE WHO FEEL EXACTLY
AS I DO AND ALL FEEL THAT NOW IS
NOT THE TIME FOR BUSINESS PEOPLE
TO SIT BACK AND NOT SPEAK OUT.
NOW IS THE TIME, AS DID EARLIER,
TO SPEAK OUT AND SAY WHAT
RUSSIA'S DOING IS UNACCEPTABLE.
AND SO I THINK WHAT WE AS A
BUSINESS COMMUNITY ARE ASKING
FOR IS FIRST, THAT MILITARY AID
IS URGENTLY NEEDED, A LOT MORE
THAN IS CURRENT LAY BEING GIVEN
TO UKRAINE.
AND WE JUST MUST GET UKRAINIANS
THE WEAPONS AND THE PROTECTIVE
GEAR AND EVERYTHING THEY NEED,
AND THE SECOND THING IS THAT IT
IS PREPOSTEROUS THAT EUROPE
CONTINUES TO SEND CHECKS
EVERYDAY TO RUSSIA FOR OIL, GAS
AND COAL.
THAT MUST STOP AND MUST STOP
IMMEDIATELY.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, WHAT WE'VE
SAID TO OURSELVES IS IF WE WERE
POLITICIANS RUNNING GERMANY, HOW
WOULD WE STOP IT?
AND THE KINDS OF ANSWERS WE'VE
COME UP WITH, FOR INSTANCE, IF
ALL IEA COUNTRIES COULD DROP THE
SPEED LIMIT BY 10 MILES AN HOUR,
THAT WOULD BE MORE BARRELS THAN
GERMANY AND OTHER EUROPEAN
COUNTRIES IMPORT FROM RUSSIA
OVERNIGHT SAVED AND THEREFORE
ANY DISADVANTAGE, YOU KNOW,
GERMANY COULD, JUST STOP BUYING
OIL.
>> SO OBVIOUSLY, THE IDEA OF
CUTTING THE SPEED LIMIT, TURNING
DOWN THERMOSTATS, SWITCHING OFF
AIR CONDITIONING ALL THESE SORT
OF THINGS WILL HAVE AN
INCREMENTAL EFFECT BUT WHEN THE
GERMAN CHANCELLOR SAYS LOOK, IT
WILL HAVE A VERY BAD EFFECT ON
THE GERMAN ECONOMY, AND THEREBY
THE REST OF EUROPE WILL SUFFER
EVEN MORE THAN IT'S SUFFERING AT
THE MOMENT BECAUSE OF THE WAR,
DO YOU NOT CUT SOME SLACK TO
GIVE THEM TIME TO CUT BACK BY
THE END OF THE YEAR?
>> I'M AN ENTREPRENEUR, BUSINESS
MAN, WHAT I KNOW IS IF YOU DO
WHAT THE IEA SAYS AND TAKE
2.7 MILLION BARRELS A DAY OUT OF
THE OIL MARKET, WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN IS COUNTRIES THAT ARE
IMPORTING OIL FROM GERMANY NEED
NOT IMPORT IT ANYMORE BECAUSE
THERE WILL BE PLENTY OF OIL
AROUND.
THE PRICE OF OIL WILL COLLAPSE,
THAT WILL BRING DOWN INFLATION.
AND EVERY SINGLE WESTERN COUNTRY
WILL BENEFIT.
AND IT'S, YOU KNOW, THERE ARE
SIMPLE MEASURES TO AND, YOU
KNOW, TO ANSWER WHAT RUSSIA'S
DOING BY THE WEST AND IT'S NOT
PAINFUL.
LIKE, YOU KNOW, DURING COVID, WE
COULDN'T DRIVE A CAR AT ALL.
ASKING US TO DRIVE A TRUCK OR
CAR AT 10 MILES AN HOUR LESS
SPEED IS NOT A BIG ASK.
IT'S NOT GOING TO AFFECT OUR
LIVES MASSIVELY.
AND IF YOU ALSO THEN ADD ON TOP
OF THAT, YOU KNOW, TO HAVE EVERY
SINGLE BUSINESS TO LOOK AT
THEMSELVES AND SEE HOW THEY CAN
CUT BACK BY 3 OR 5%, YOU WILL
SEE A COLLAPSE IN THE OIL PRICE
AND THAT WILL BENEFIT EVERYBODY.
>> YOU SAY AS WELL YOUR FELLOW
TEAM LEAD OFS SAID NOW IS NOT
THE TIME FOR NEUTRALITY.
TODAY WE HAVE FOR EXAMPLE
WIMBLETON SAYING RUSSIA CAN'T
COMPETE, THERE IS A DISPUTE,
SOME SAY ATHLETES SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO NOT VISIT THE SINS OF
THE COUNTRY ON THE INDIVIDUALS
AND VICE VERSA SO THERE'S AN
ARGUMENT AND A DEBATE GOING ON,
BUT WHEN I READ YOUR LETTER,
IT'S SORT OF VERY CLEAR, NOW IS
THE TIME TO TAKE STANDS.
>> YEAH, LOOK.
I'M FRIENDS WITH SOME OF THOSE
PLAYERS WHO ARE GOING TO BE
STOPPED FROM PLAYING AT
WIMBLETON BUT ALSO FRIENDS WITH
DOCTORS, NURSES, RECEPTIONISTS
WHO ARE PICKING UP GUNS IN
UKRAINE AND HAVING TO FIGHT FOR
THEIR COUNTRY AND, YOU KNOW,
THAT IS A FAR BIGGER CROSS TO
BEAR THAN A TENNIS PLAYER BEING
TOLD THEY CAN'T PLAY AT
WIMBLETON SO I THINK WE GOT TO
BE BREAK AND WHITE ON THIS, BY
THE WAY, TINKOV, I JUST HEARD
THE STATEMENT HE'S PUT OUT.
I KNOW HIM PERSONALLY, BY THE
WAY HE'S NOT AN OLIGARCH.
HE WAS A SELF-MADE RUSSIAN WHO
BUILT A REALLY SUCCESSFUL BANK
IN RUSSIA AND IS REALLY
INCREDIBLY BRAVE, THE STATEMENT
HE PUT OUT TONIGHT, AND THERE
ARE A LOT OF OTHER RUSSIAN
BUSINESS PEOPLE I KNOW WHO FEEL
EQUA